Director David Gordon Green's Halloween, the
reboot-sequel that directly connects to John
Carpenter's original film and retcons the
many less-awesome follow-ups that came after
it, featured an ending that finally gave Laurie
Strode, played by Jamie Lee Curtis, the closure
she'd sought for 40 years, while keeping Michael
Myers' fate relatively open for interpretation.
But Halloween almost concluded on much different
note.
Obviously if you've come this far in this
video you should know: spoilers for the 2018
Halloween ahead.
By the end of the film, Laurie, her daughter
Karen, and her granddaughter Allyson trapped
Michael inside Laurie's basement, then set
the entire house ablaze.
It'd have been safe to assume Michael would
be burnt to a crisp until the film cut back
to the flame-filled basement that now appeared
to be Michael-free.
Fans who stayed through the credits heard
his breathing just before the lights went
up, which further signaled that he may have
made it out of the fire alive.
But an early version of the film saw things
play out differently.
In a May 2017 script draft posted to Twitter,
Laurie, Allyson, and Karen originally named
"Shanah" come together outside Laurie's house,
where Laurie engages in a one-on-one battle
with Michael.
Rather than a game of cat and mouse that ends
up with Michael locked in the basement, the
alternate ending sees Laurie and Michael getting
into a knife-fight outside.
Laurie's luck against Michael runs out when
he drives a knife into her chest.
She swings her own knife and slices his arm.
Here's where Karen/"Shanah" enters the scene,
slowly opening the front door, armed with
"a high tech crossbow."
After Michael twists the knife further, "forces
[Laurie] to the ground," and then "pulls the
blade out," Laurie's daughter shoots Michael
in the chest — at least that's what we can
assume happened.
There's a page missing from the Halloween
script that was shared on social media.
Next we see Laurie's daughter and granddaughter
flagging down a pick-up truck, loading Laurie
in it, and pulling away with the unnamed driver
seemingly in search of a hospital, somewhat
similarly to the way the final cut of the
film ends.
The script then cuts to a dark forest, where
Michael staggers through the trees as he yanks
an arrow out of his chest.
He ends up "standing among the shattered artificial
faces of mannequins" — likely a reference
to the area of Laurie's property where she
and her daughter held target practice, which
we saw in the film.
He then walks to a tree and sits down, touches
the wounds in his chest and looks at his missing
fingers, all while breathing laboriously.
As the script notes, he's exhausted, and possibly
taking his final breath.
Compared to how Halloween actually ended — Laurie,
Karen, and Allyson having survived and only
Michael's ultimate fate left ambiguous — this
original conclusion would have featured Laurie
and Michael both on the brink of death.
Pretty thrilling, and more than enough room
for a sequel, right?
So why didn't they go with this version?
Two words: test audiences.
The filmmakers held reshoots after test audiences
made it known that they didn't like the ending
very much.
And as cool as a knife-fight and crossbow
scene would've been, it's hard not to agree.
Sure, the original ending sounds pretty solid
in most regards, but it was probably a good
thing that it was changed for the final cut.
Imagine it: Laurie anxiously awaiting Michael's
return for 40 years, training and raising
her daughter to fight and kill him, to the
point where the authorities had to take her
away — only to be stabbed and left bleeding
in the back of a pick-up truck?
That would've been a massive bummer.
With critics and fans having highly praised
Halloween, and the flick raking in hundreds
of millions of dollars at the global box office,
it's all but inevitable that we haven't seen
the last of Michael, Laurie, Karen, and Allyson.
Maybe Laurie will still get to have that knife
fight, and Karen will hoist the crossbow for
another moment of utter badassery, in the
possible sequel?
A horror fan can only hope.